is the problem with privileged often
white liberals as they think everything
should be fair and oftentimes they grew
up in the most unfair thing because we
came from two parent homes and
oftentimes well-off neighborhoods and
then we're whining about fairness yeah I
want everybody we have the ultimate
Advantage ever and that's why I want
everybody to live a good life no but
then and so what they do is they go
everywhere and whine and complain
instead of get on with it they go into
these male workplaces and and
complain men don't complain they just do
that's the difference between men and
women as men just do things
as well